have you ever seen anything like this
this or this so many companies nowadays
just make the same products over and
over and they copy each other and that
is where our Channel partner pataka
comes in making some very unique
accessories all while being high quality
and affordable now they are known for
the cases and it's actually the only
case that I wanted to consistently use
with my iPhone 13 Pro so when they
reached out when they said that their
new cases are now even better and they
showed me all their other accessories
that blew my mind I said all right let's
go ahead and do a product showcase now
in the past I was never a huge fan of
cases because you take your nice
expensive device you put this thick
ugly cheap feeling case on it even if
you spend a lot of money and it defeats
the purpose but last year when I got one
of these patakas it was awesome now this
is the new one for the iPhone 14. I have
my Pro Max here and somehow even though
they were insanely thin last year with
the Mac easy case 3 they made it 33
thinner which is insane and 27
lighter this is the world's thinnest and
lightest Max 8 compatible case it is
under one millimeter thick which is
crazy while being super strong and
that's because it's made from 100
genuine aramid fibers which is the same
material that Kevlar bulletproof vests
are made of and the mag easy case 3
looks sharp with this really nice
texture and a raised camera lip to
protect your fancy 48 megapixel camera
pataka also has their patent-pending few
Fusion weaved cases which is what I'm
using on my personal 14 pro Max it looks
super cool it's hard to do and it is
real fibers that are weaved with a
different color you guys can see the
different styles they have right here we
have the smaller version of mine and
this other really nice looking one now
they have two densities a 600D and a
1500 D that is slightly thicker but
still super lightweight now one thing
you guys might not know is that some
cases will actually interfere with
magsafe charging and slow it down if the
magnets are too strong or not placed
perfectly so pataka has optimized for
that to get the fastest speed and also
so that the case doesn't interfere with
NFC or anything else which I have
experienced in the past now if you want
a little bit more protection than the
mag easy case 3 they have the mag easy
case Pro 3 which is not that much
thicker or heavier but offers you really
good protection now one thing I want to
point out is their new packaging this
packaging is made from 100 crushed sugar
cane which is called big ass if I'm
saying that correctly and that means
that this is 100
biodegradable so not only can you
recycle it it will literally degrade on
its own now as you guys can see this
thing has a nice soft interior design is
different and pataka is extremely proud
of this Fusion technology which has a
seamless connection between the TPU and
the air mid fibers this is not just a
layer that is glued on top like other
cases have it is a perfect perfect seal
that you can't even feel your phone pops
right in here and then it grips the side
with the TPU you have your buttons fully
covered and they're really easy to press
same thing with the volume rocker and
you also have that nice raised lip
that's a little bit wider this time to
protect your cameras so if you're
looking for a little bit more protection
on the sides something that's still
lightweight and not too thick check out
the pro case 3 from the mag easy series
or just get the original one that is
insanely thin and light all links down
below and now let me show you the rest
of the insane accessories this is the
pataka pita tag which is the world's
first multi-tool air tag holder and the
build quality is absolutely incredible
it is all metal it is super easy to put
in in your air tag and then take it out
if you need to change your battery it's
very very secure and at the same time as
holding your air tag which there are
many holders out there that all cop each
other uh the build quality is not good
why not get something that not only
holds your ear tag but also offers you a
flathead screwdriver a Phillips
screwdriver a hex screwdriver and a mini
pocket knife right here so that not only
can you find your keys you also have all
these tools readily available whenever
you need them and then at the same time
your Loop here is very close and it is
high quality with this nice little latch
to keep the rest of your keys close to
you and very compact I thought that was
Genius of pataka to invent this now if
that's not your style check this out
this is incredible it's the world's
first air tag holder which also has a
lightning cable built in once again we
have the aramid fibers right there and
this cable is insanely high quality has
that braided like cable finish and
whenever you need a charging cable you
simply unscrew this and you literally
have a USBC on one end and a lightning
on the other this is a really nice
material I think this is aluminum right
here and it is magnetic so you literally
pop it together and screw it back on or
open it up and here you go at any time
you have your cable with you if you need
to charge up your phone your air pods or
whatever else this is why I love pataka
just that innovation in just like their
multi-tool airtight holder none of these
have any sort of interference for the
speaker or the signal nothing like that
speaking of airpods if you want to match
the Mac easy case 3 for your iPhone 14
series they also have the mag easy case
for your air pods now previously I was
like why would you really want a case
for your air pods you know it does add a
little bit of bulk but in this case it
looks nice it matches your finish and
with my air pods after using them
throwing in a bag with other tools with
keys look how horrible this looks right
here I mean this is really bad three
years of use it looks horrendous so
obviously those of you guys that want to
match and you want something that looks
clean and that won't scratch your stuff
up especially if you want to sell it
later if you're going to upgrade to the
next year you guys could check this one
out now the next one you guys already
know that I absolutely love and that is
their carbon fiber watch band for the
Apple watch now unlike other ones on the
market that are plastic and then they
just have a single little layer of
carbon fiber that's glued on or it's
just fake printed carbon fiber this is
completely out of carbon fiber you guys
see all of those layers and the few
additions are stainless steel for
example you have this clasp right here
that is magnetic uh it is not some kind
of a cheap material and even with that
this thing weighs an incredible 1.1
ounce it is shockingly shockingly
lightweight and that is because it
literally is five times lighter than
metal and five times stronger now this
band right here is the style that I have
they also have one that looks a little
bit different if you like that style
better and my favorite feature other
than the look and the weight is this
clasp check out how easy this is for
that to clasp on bam I literally brought
them together and the magnets attached
attached it is super sturdy because once
the magnets bringing together the little
clasp holds on you have these little
bars on the side and to open it up check
this out bam that is it so I absolutely
love this watch band it is one of my
favorites so if you like carbon fiber
you want something that is real carbon
fiber and not crazy expensive cheaper
than a lot of apples bands that are way
less money to make this thing is awesome
they have links included in the box with
some of them that are slightly larger
size so you can get the perfect fit now
for your watch they have the power
dongle charger which is see-through it
looks really cool has this cap right
here that magnetically attaches they
love magnets and high quality things so
this can actually plug into their next
accessory but you can also plug it into
your MacBook it is ultra thin so you can
charge your Apple watch anywhere I plug
it into my trucks USB C Port so it
barely sticks out this is no cable and
when I need to top off I'm commuting bam
I put it on there give it a nice charge
so it is nice and small and very
lightweight very convenient just toss
into your bag so you have it with you
anywhere and anywhere there's a USB
type-c port even just a power bank you
pop it on and you have a charger and
this is their unique modular mag easy
slider charger for the iPhone 12s 13s
and 14 series it has a couple awesome
features from the base it comes with
their 4 000 milliamp hour Wireless
magnetic power pack this has a USB
type-c on here and it just slides right
in here you leave it on you attach your
phone and it's going to charge it at
night it has a very strong hold and it
also fits the iPhone 14 pro the smaller
one has enough clearance for that huge
camera bump there are other brands that
have flat Chargers where this does not
work with these new large camera bumps
and the really cool thing is that say
your phone is dad you forgot to charge
it or it's low and you're going out
somewhere you literally slide off the
magnetic power pack has a button right
here that you press to turn it on and
you pop it on your phone bam you have
your power pack with you whenever you
need it and then when you don't you
leave it on the actual charger itself
use it as pass-through charging and it
is always charged ready on the go so
what happens when you want to charge
your airpods well they have this really
cool magnetically attached little stand
you can put it on one way or you can
spin it around and put it lower so
depending on whatever kind of airpods
you have you literally set them down
behind the stand it is out of the way
it's not bulky on your desk and it's
going to charge up your earpods now if
you want to charge an Apple Watch as
well that is where you have the power
dongle which you can buy separately or
you can buy a set altogether it plugs
into the side and then you have a
charger for your your Apple watch as
well pataka also has some unique car
chargers as well which are very cool for
a few reasons of course it is a wireless
car charger so it will work for your
iPhones with magsafe even if you don't
have their case it holds on nice and
strong and if you do have one with a
case the attachment is even stronger it
is insanely strong but with that if you
have say a Samsung s22 phone you can use
one of the cases for that like the Mac
easy case too and you can also get full
15 watt Wireless fast charging for that
phone as well so if you have two phones
or say your friends have one of those
phones or a spouse you can charge that
as well with full speed and with a great
magnetic connection now this thing also
has a fan built into here and one of the
biggest issues with wireless chargers in
your car is that if you're using
something like GPS with 5G the phones
heat up the screen dims the battery
battery charging slows down and then at
times it's not even charging I've had
that happen many times where this thing
will have a fan that can kick on to keep
it cool and charging fast it has this
ball mount so you can adjust the angle
this clip also tightens up and if you
don't have events in your car they also
have a version of this charger that has
a windshield mount or they have the
sticky pad that you can put on your
dashboard and a flat object so you can
mount it there so whatever kind of
vehicle you have or however it's set up
you can use this charger and the last
one is pataka's mag easy card sleeve
three so obviously it is a wallet it is
very durable it has this magnetic plate
in here so not only does it hold your
business cards credit cards it has this
access slot right here but it also
attaches to magsafe so without a case it
will still attach but the way it is
designed if you attach it to one of
their cases either the mag easy case to
the Pro or for the new line with a 3 and
3 Pro it has an insane connection
because it also has additional magnets
here not only the mag safe and with that
it doesn't only work on phones it also
will work with their cases like the iPad
one so in here they also have magnets
attached so the extra plate that's in
here with those additional magnets will
hold on to your iPad if you want to have
some business cards in there or whatever
so it's a little bit more flexible than
other options on the market so now you
guys get why I love pataka and their
Innovative unique products like their
cases they're ultra slim along with
these other crazy accessories that
nobody has thought about doing if you
guys want to check them all out I have
links down in the video description
below click above if you guys want to
subscribe to see more videos like this
one and check out one other great video
right over there this one Max and I'll
see you in the next one
[Music]